البدايه من غازي عنتاب في جنوب تركيا في
وقت يشتد فيه سباق فرق الانقاذ مع الزمن
للعثور على احياء تحت نقاد المشهد متكرر
في المدينه وعشرات المدن المتضرره الاخرى
ومن اعزاز في ريف حلب تصلنا هذه الصور في
نهايه اليوم الخامس بعد زلزال الامال في
العثور على احيان ما زالت قائمه لكنها
للاسف تتضاه
والى الغربي من ريف حلب تقع ادلب وريفها
بما في ذلك معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع
تركيا والذي تصلون منه هذه الصور بعد ساعه
من عبور قافله منه تابعه للامم المتحده
مكونه من اربع عشره شاحنه محمله بموادتها
وفي عناوين الليله
بعد اكثر من 100 ساعه على زلزال جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا اخراج اشخاص عده
بينهم نساء واطفال على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاذ
وفرق متخصصه من عشرات البلدان تواصل البحث
عن مزيد من النجين وسط برداس
مع اقتراب الزلزال المدمر من اكمال يومه
الخامس عدد الضحايا في تركيا يرتفع الى
اكثر من 20 الف قتيل وثمانين الف جريح
وزير الخارجيه التركيه يقول للجزيره ان
ثلاثه عشر مليون تركي تاثروا بالكارثه
والزلزال يصنف في المرتبه السابعه بين
اكثر الكوارث الطبيعيه فتكا في القرن
الحالي
اكثر من 3600 قتيل جراء الزلزال في عموم
سوريا غافله المساعدات ثانيه من الامم
المتحده تدخل شمال سوريا
منظمه القوه البيضاء تعتبر استجابه الامم
المتحده للزجلان كارثيه وتصف ما اعتبرته
بطئا في دخول المساعدات وضاءالتها
بالجريمه والامم المتحده تدعو الى تنحيه
السياسه جانبا لتسهيل دعم المحتاجين
لمساعده نحو 900 الف شخص بحاجه ماسه
للغذاء في تركيا وسوريا الامم المتحده
تطلب تمويلا بس 77 مليون دولار برنامج
الغذاء العالمي يقول ان مخزونه نفد في
شمال غرب سوريا ويدعو الى فتح مزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
مرت عده ساعات بعد المئه منذ زلزال
المدمره الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وفرق
الانقاذ لا تفقد الامل في العثور على
ناجين تحت ركام تحققت امنيات البعض
بالنجاه لكن الاموات بالعشرات عشرات
الالاف واستتوقعات بارتفاعهم بعد انتهاء
عمليات رفع الانقاذ المستمره ليلا ونهارا
في ظروف صعبه للغايه قصص كثيره عن العوده
الى الحياه بعد موت وشيك وعن مقابر جماعيه
لعائلات باكملها
محمد محمد حي يرزق اخيرا ابصر النورة بعد
اكثر من 100 ساعه تحت الركب
[موسيقى]
جدا
يسال عن جده ويطمئن قلبه قبل ان يلتقي في
سياره الاسعاف اخاه يوسف الذي نجاه وايضا
النهايه السعيده لكابوس الاثنين الماضي
استثناء في كارثه زلزال هو الاسوا في
تركيا وسوريا منذ عام 39 من القرن الماضي
الامل في العثور على احياء تحت الكتل
الخرسانيه في المناطق المنكوبه يقابله رقم
مرعب لعدد القتلى الذي تجاوز 20 الف لم
تنتشر كل الجثث ورفع الانقاض سيستغرق وقتا
طويلا
سيكون اطول في المناطق السوريه التي تفتقر
الى المعدات اللازمه وفرق الانقاذ بالعدد
المطلوب لمواجهه الماساه على اطلال
المباني سلاسل بشريه تعمل ضد الياس
والظروف المناخيه الصعبه لا يهون على عمال
الانقاص ومثل هذه اللحظات الاقرب الى
المعجزه عندما يكتب عمر جديد للرضيع او
طفل او اي ناج بعد ايام بين الموت والحياه
مهما كانت خبره بعض عمل الانقاذ ثمه لحظه
لا يمكن فيها مقاومه البكاء
اللحظه الاصعب هي هذه عندما تدفن ام
ابنتها او شده حفيدتها حداد اديمان مفتوح
كباقي المناطق المنكوبه جنازات لا تنتهي
واحزان سيعيش معها هل الضحايا مدى الحياه
مقبره جماعيه في جبله باللاذقيه عائلات
باكملها لم تعد موجوده سوى على شواهد
القبور وفي قلوب ذويها الاف السوريين
ماتوا في زلزال زاد جرحا عميقا في بلد
ينزف منذ سنوات في بلد اللجوء ليجد بعضهم
سوى الحدائق العامه للبقاء فيها الى اشعار
اخر هذا حالهم في غاز عنتاب وعيدوا بخيم
لم تصل وبمساعده تاخرت
بقلوب يعتصرها الالم تعلو التكبيرات
والدعوات في مدينه كهرمان مراش اختفى جزء
كبير من عمران المدينه ومن فيها بفعل
الزلزال حضر المصلون في جمعه تكررت فيها
الدعوه عبر اسقاع المعموره بالرحمه
للضحايا تمر ايام الانتظار المر على البعض
اقصى طموحهم العصور على جثه قريبا لاكرامه
ليلا ونهارا تحفر سواعد الالاف وسط الخراب
بحثا عن احياء واموات قال احد المسعفين
انها الساعات الاخيره ونعمل بالسرعه نحاول
ان ندرك الاحياء في الرمق الاخير
من عزاز في حلب معنا مراسلنا محمد
الجزائري من معبر باب الهوى على الحدود
السوريه التركيه مراسلنا ادهم ابو الحسام
ومن غازي عنتاب مراسلنا منتصر ابو نبوت
اهلا بهم جميعا نبدا من عزاز واخر ملاحم
ملامح المشهد لديك محمد الجزائري
نعم محمد في الحقيقه المشهد ما يزال يزداد
سوءا ساعه بعد ساعه فهذه القيام التي هي
خلفي تزداد العائلات الوافده اليها ساعه
بعد ساعه مع استمرار نزوح الاهالي الذين
فقدوا منازلهم فنشاهد هذه الخيام نحن هنا
هذه القيام الثلاثه التي هي قيامه كبيره
تم انشاؤها من قبل متطوعون يقين فيها
حاليا النساء والاطفال ينامون في هذه
الخيام هؤلاء الاهاليهم نازحون من المناطق
التي تضررت كمدينه سرمدا والاتارض ومدينه
جنديرس بالاضافه الى ان بعض الاهالي في من
هذه المدينه التي هؤلاء الاهل الذي تضررت
منازلهم في الحقيقه تحدثنا اليهم منذ قليل
وقالوا لنا ان المنازلهم تضررت وبعض
الجدران قد تصدعت ومنهم من قال لنا ان
الاعمده الاساسات المنازل قد منازلهم قد
تصدعت واتضررت ينتظرون فرق من المهندسين
لتقييم حال هذه الايام هذه المنازل لمعرفه
ان كان يمكن السكن فيها او لا حقيقه
الشباب يجلسون في العراء خلال الساعات
الليل رغم شده البرد ورغم البرد الشديد
بالدرجات الحراره المنخفضه جدا نشاهد
الشباب يجلسون في هذه الزاويه حتى ساعات
الصباح ينتظرون بذور الفجر ليتم تفريغ احد
الخيام
من النساء والاطفال
يترقوا قصه من الراحه حقيقه هناك
شده هناك غضب شعبي كبير من هؤلاء الاهالي
من ما تقدمه المنظمات المحليه ومن الفرق
الانسانيه
لقله المساعدات وقله ما يقدم لهم من
مساعدات حقيقه نحن نتحدث عن عدد كبير من
الضحايا وعدد كبير من المتضررين وامام
امكانيات محدوده جدا تقدمه المنظمات
الانسانيه الاهالي يطالبون
بدعم ربما بخيام
ليقيموا فيها او يقيموها بالقرب من
منازلهم التي تضررت الى حين معرفه مصير
منازلهم ومعرفه مصير مكان الذي سيقيمون
فيه حقيقه سالنا الاهالي في حال انهم
لماذا
يتجاوزون عن مساعدات المنظمات الانسانيه
ويقومون بشراء خيام ويمشيوها بالقرب من
منازلهم ولكن تحدثوا لنا ان هذه
تكلفتها كبيره جدا في القيام المصنعه في
محليا هنا قد تصل تكلفه الخيمه وثمنها الى
اكثر من ما يقارب 200 دولار ومما عدا عن
الاثاث والعوازل التي يحتاجونها من
لانشاء هذه القيم مخصصه لكلفه الى اكثر من
400 دولار وهم عائلات فقيره حقيقه لا
يمكنهم تحمل اعضاء هذه التكاليف الاهالي
عددهم كبير جدا نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 2000
شخص فقدوا حياتهم في الشمال السوري
بالاضافه الى ربما ضعف هذا العدد ورابط
هذا العدد من الذين اصيبوا
الذين تضرروا جراء هذا الزلزال نحن نشاهد
ماساه كبيره للاهالي يتحدثون عن قصص
عاشوها قصص مرعبه عاشوها بعضهم من نجى
باعجوبه من تحت بعضهم من انتشل اطفاله
وذهب للعراء خلال ساعات الزلزال الاولى
ويقيم حاليا في هذه القيم المؤقته لمعرفه
مصير المصير الى اين سيحط بها المصير واين
سيقيم في الايام القادمه شكرا لك محمد
الجزائري كنت معنا من عزاز الان الى معبر
باب الهوى وادهم ابو الحسام تفضل ادهم
نعم محمد للاسف ما زالت الضحايا تتوافد
تباعا من الجانب التركي الى معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا لنجول بالكاميرا
قليلا وترى عشرات الاشخاص من ذوي الضحايا
الذين ينتظرون الدفعه القادمه لربما تصل
بعد دقائق
غالبيتهم من قضاء جراء كهرمان مارش في
ولايه ايضا هناك الكثير من الضحايا التي
تحدث عنهم المكتب الطبي في معمر باب الهوى
الحدود مع تركيا ويقول ان في ساحه البلديه
فيها تاي الان اكثر من خمسين ضحيه وهم
جميعهم من السوريين الذين نقضوا في مدينه
انطاكيا وايضا في بعض الولايات الاخرى اذا
اردنا الحديث من هنا من معبر باب الهوى
وما رصدناه عن المساعدات الانسانيه نستطيع
ان نؤكد ايضا في هذه اللحظات عن دخول
قافله
ظهر هذا اليوم مؤلفه من اربعه عشر شاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه اضافه الى خيام
وتجهيزاتها اللوجستيه وكان قبل يومين ايضا
كانت قد دخلت قافله امميه ضمن برنامج
الاغاثه العالمي الاعتيادي
ايضا ضمن مواد اغاثيه وخيام وايضا دخلت
قافله من معبر باب السلامه الحدودي 14
شاحنه مقدمه من اقليم كردستان العراق الى
تصل الى مدينه جنديرس لتوزع ضمن الاولويات
على المتضررين من هذا الزلزال ولكن
القائمين على العمل الانساني هنا في شمال
غرب سوريا يقولون ان المساعدات خجوله
وللاسف جاءت متاخره كثيرا خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالمعدات الثقيله الدفاع المدني
السوري يتحدث عن خيبه امل كبيره شعر بها
هو وفرقه كاداره وفرق اضافه الى ان
الكوادر الطبيه هنا في الشمال السوري ايضا
شعرت بخيبه امل كبيره حيث لم يصل اي
مساعدات طبيه ولا معدات ثقيله لتساعد في
انتشاء الضحايا من تحت الانقاض او حتى
اجلاء جثه الضحايا من تحت الركام التي ما
زالت عالقه حتى هذه الساعه الاحتياجات
محمد كبيره جدا نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 5000
مصاب هنا في شمال غرب سوريا المستشفيات
يعني الاحتياجات فقط قدره المستشفيات هنا
في شمال غرب سوريا الكوادر الطبيه استنزفت
استنزفت بشكل كامل خلال الايام الماضيه
نتحدث عن خمسه ايام من العمل المتواصل
سواء من فرق دفاع المدني او الكوادر
الطبيه
الان الى غازي عنتاب ومنتصر ابو نبوت
منتصر
نعم محمد يعني الصوره لا تختلف كثيرا في
غازي عنتاب اعمال بحث مستمره والاف
الاشخاص في الشوارع وفي الساحات العامه
وفي الحدائق بالاضافه الى
مساعدات تستمر بالوصول قبل قليل كانت
طائرات عسكريه تحلق وطائرات شحن تحلق في
سماء غازي عنتاب وهو ضمن الخط الجسر الجوي
الذي يتحدث عنه وزير الدفاع التركي اقف
هنا في احدى المباني التي تهدمت جراء هذا
الزلزال هذا المبنى خرج منه نحو اربعه
وعشرين شخصا
عشرين عشرين شخصا منهم احياء واربعه لقوا
حتفهم بحسب ابلغونا فرق الانقاذ ان هناك
خمسه اشخاص لا يزال يحاولون البحث عنهم
يمكن من خلال هذه اللقطات المباشره ان
نقرب الصوره قليلا هذه الاعمال وهذا البحث
لم يتوقف في مدينه غازي عنتاب منذ اللحظات
الاولى ايضا
اليوم كان وزير الاسكان في زياره الى
المناطق التي تعرضت للدمار في غازي عنتاب
برفقه رئيسه بلديه غازي عنتاب فاطمه شاهين
وتحدث عن نصب خمسه عشر الف خيمه وقال ان
هذا عدد سيتم رفعه الى خمسه وعشرين الف
خيمه بالاضافه الى 500 منزل متنقل وايضا
بلديه غازي عنتاب تحدثت عن توزيع 500 الف
وجبه يوميا على الاشخاص الفارين في
الشوارع وفي
الحدائق وقالت انها حددت النقاط لهذا
التوزيع لتوزيع الوجبات الساخنه على
الفارين من هذا الزلزال وايضا من ضمن هذه
المناطق هي هنا منطقه ساحه الديمقراطيه
الساحه المشهوره في مدينه غازي عين تاب
وايضا
فاطمه شاهين رئيسه البلديه رافقت وزير
الاسكان في هذه الجوله وذهبوا الى منطقه
الاصلاحيه هذه المنطقه تعرضت لدمار كبير
جراء هذا الزلزال ايضا نورداغيه تتبع
لولايه غازي عنتاب هذه المنطقه اليوم اخرج
منها ام
وطفليها من تحت الانقاذ وكانوا لا يزالون
على قيد الحياه وايضا فرق الانقاذ التابعه
فرق القاضي القطريه اخرجت هنا في مدينه
غازي عنتاب ام وطفلتها من تحت وطفلها من
تحت الالقاب
في احد المواقع التي تهدمت في مدينه غازي
عنتاب جراء هذا الزلزال شكرا لك منتصر ابو
نبوت من غازي عنتاب
مع مضيه اكثر من مئه ساعه وتضاؤل الامل في
وجود ناجين بدات تفاصيل انقاذ جديده تحكي
ما هو اقرب للمعجزات
ربيعه
البالغه من العمر 27 عاما من تحت الانقاض
والركام بعد 120 ساعات وكانما يتحدى واقع
الحال واصرار المنقذين مختلف الهمسات التي
تتحدثه عن تراجع فرص العثور على ناجين
[موسيقى]
وهنا في كهرمان مرعش انقذت الفرق العامله
رجلا ظل محاصرا تحت انقراض الزلزال لمده
140 ساعات يتلو الرجل ايات من القران
الكريم بينما يجري نقله
[تصفيق]
تروي الصور وتفاصيل مذهله اخرى وكانما
التمسك بالامل يهزم مختلف العبارات التي
تفقي بضعف احتمالات العثور على ناجين
ويلهم فرق الانقاذ التي تعمل في ظروف
بالغه التعقيد في المضي قدما بحثا عن اي
حياه تخرج بين الانقراض المميته
[موسيقى]
وعلى الرغم من مرور اكثر من مئه ساعه من
وقوع الزلزال المدمر تواصل فرق الانقاذ
مسابقه الزمن بحثا عن ناجين وحتى عن ضحايا
ما زالت تحاصرهم الالقاب
صحيح ان احتمال العثور على احياء بعد هذه
المده قد يكون استثنائيا لكنه ليس بمستحيل
هذا قد اظهرت صور بثها الدفاع المدني
السوري عمليه انقاذ اسره مكونه من اب وام
وثلاثه اطفال في قريه بسنه غربي ادلب وذكر
الدفاع المدني المعروف بالخوذه البيضاء ان
هذه العمليه تاتي ضمن مئات العمليات التي
نفذها منذ وقوع الزلزال
[موسيقى]
وفي ولايه هاتايا الجنوبيه تركيا تواصل
فرق الانقاذ عمليات البحث عن احياء او
ضحايا وسط ركام المباني التي تهدمت بفعل
الزلزال وتوابعه والذي تضررت منه الولايه
بشده خاصه في مدينه انطاكيا كبرى حواضرها
حيث تهدمت اعداد كبيره من مبانيها السكنيه
والخدميه وتصدعت اغلبيه المباني في مركز
المدينه في وقت تاخر فيه وصوله فرق
الاسعاف
ومما اعاق البحث ورفع الانقاد
تعب سنين طويله انفق في بناء هذا البيت
وفي ثوان مزلزله خلخله اساساته
اب وام وابناء واحفاد بات مصيرهم التشرد
لا يجرؤون على دخول منزلهم ومن بعيد
يراقبونه
كانت
بالجنه
وراح البيت وراحوا المصاري ما بقى
عايشين بيجيبوا من برا اللي بيجيب شغله
بيعطينا خبز بيضه
يعني اي شيء في معايير انطاكيا ما بعد
الزلزال تعد هذه الاسره محظوظه نجى جميع
افرادها الا من كسر في ذراع هذا الفتى كان
اخر الهاربين وانهار جزء من درج البيت على
ذراعه
في مركز مدينه انطاكيا يتكشف حجم الكارثه
لا تكاد ترى بنايه سالمه بشكل كامل هنا
ترك الزلزال اثره في كل مكان
فتحت البنايات المهدمه تتحطم امال اقارب
العالقين في نجاتهم كلما مر الوقت
تتكثف مساعي فرق الانقاذ مع وصول المعدات
الى المدينه النائيه لكن عدد البنايات
المتضرره كبير وعدد فرق البحث والتنقيب
محدود ولا سبيل الى تلبيه كل نداءات
الاستغاثه
من بين هؤلاء المستغيثين مروان ترك في هذا
البيت زوجه وطفله في عامها الثالث
اذا حدا عم يسمعني يرد
لم يفقد الامل بعد في نجاتهم وينتظر ان
يصل دوره لتبدا عمليه رفع الانقاض
يستبد به الحنين والاحساس بالعجز امام
واقع المرير
طعم النوم ماني
قطعه تحت
الوعود او
[موسيقى]
البنايات التي تهدمت بسبب زلزال في تركيا
توجد هنا في ولايه هاتاي بعد مرور ايام
على الواقع تعيش المدينه بلا كهرباء ولا
خدمات هاتف وحاله اختناق مروري تصاعب وصول
سياره الاسعاف في الوقت المناسب
ووسط كل هذا تتواتر قصص نجاه ملهمه لاهالي
العالقين فبعد مرور 84 ساعه يخرج هذا
الطفل من بين الركام بجهود المسعفين كما
هي الا دقائق حتى اخرج فرق الانقاذ احد
اقاربه
خلف كل قطعه ركام هنا طفوله واحلام
وذكريات وسعي لعيش افضل بعد زلزال تغيرت
الاولويات
وبدانا بالبحث عن احبتهم وكلهم امل في
ايجادهم واسعافهم وابقائهم على قيد الحياه
اما الاخرون فصارت الاولويات متغيره البحث
عن ماوى وعن الغذاء وعن الماء صار اولويه
ملحه اما الكهرباء والانترنت فصارت طرفا
لا تملكه الا قله ابن الجزيره
وفي اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال تظهر صور
للاقمار الصناعيه حجم الدمار الذي حل
بالمناطق المنكوبه وتعكس هذه الصور حقيقه
الضرر الذي لحق بهذه المناطق واثره في
الاقتصاد التركي
لم يبقى شيء كما كان قبل فجر الاثنين
هكذا كانت مدينه غازي عنتاب
هكذا اصبحت بعد دقائق فقط من الزلزال
هكذا كانت انطاكيا
هكذا اصبحت تغير شكل الحياه كثر فيها
الموت والدمار وخيام المشردين هذا ما فعله
زلزال كهرمان مراش وهزاته الارتداديه قبل
ان تشرق شمس السادس من فبرايره
الصور التي تقارن حجم الدمار تعكسها
الارقام امتد زلزال في جنوبيه تركيا
وشمالي سوريا الى مساحه اقتربت من مئه الف
كيلو متر مربع تلك مساحه تجاوزت مساحات
الدول في العالم هولندا البرتغال النمسا
سويسرا كل هذه الدول مساحاتها اقل من
المساحه التي ضربها الزلزال الاخير لا
احصائيات النهائيه حتى الان عن البنايات
المنهاره لكنها بالالاف او حجم الدمار في
البنيه التحتيه ولا حتى حصيله نهائيه لعدد
القتلى والجرحى والمشردين لكن اعداد
الضحايا الاحياء والاموات يتجاوز 26 مليون
انسان وهؤلاء كذلك يتجاوزون عدد سكان كثير
من الدول
المنطقه المنكوبه في تركيا تساهم باكثر من
تسعه في المئه بالمعدل من الناتج المحلي
التركي بالاضافه الى المساهمه بقرابه تسعه
في المئه من اجمالي صادرات التركيه تلك
ارقام تعادل 76 مليار دولار امريكي هذا
رقم يتجاوز ميزانيات الدول كثيره كذلك
هكذا مر الزلزال على تركيا في الجانب
السوري لا ارقى مواضحه او تفاصيل الاكيد
ان الزلزال دمر في دقائق ما بني في عقود
وانهى في تلك الدقائق كذلك ما لا يمكن
اعاده بنائه في سنوات وبعض الخسائر لا
يمكن ان تعود الى الابد
ومعنا من ملاطيا في جنوب تركيا ساره هديري
رئيسه فريق الانقاذ التابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الالبانيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيدي صار كيف
كانت مساهمتكم في عمليات الانقاذ
شكرا على اتاحه هذه الفرصه
لاشارككم تجربتنا
الفريق فريق وزاره الدفاع الالباني طبعا
طلب منا ان نادي ونساعد بلدنا الجار تركيا
وهذا امر لم يكن يتوقعوه احد وهذا الامر
الفظيع والمروع الذي حدث والذي فطر قلوبنا
جميعا
طبعا مهامنا ومسؤوليتنا اتجاه جيراننا ان
نكون قريبون من الناس في
السراء والضراء وان نساعدهم في التعافي من
الدمار وهذا الذي لاحق بهم جره الزلزال
نحن وصلنا بعد 12 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
الثاني
وطبعا التركيه
اعلنت حاله الطوارئ في المنطقه وطلبه
المساعدات من دول العالم
والوضع هنا صعب وصعب للغايه وما حدث لم
يكن متوقعا على الاطلاق حدث زلزالان
متلاحقان وضرب مدن
كبيره في المنطقه الجنوبيه من تركيا وكذلك
في الشمال السوري لكننا المتواجدون في
تركيا
اتينا بفريقين يضم
تسعين شخصا معظمهم في منطقه اضنه والقسم
في منطقه ملاطيا ونحن متواجدون الان في
ملاطيا وهذه احدى المباني التي نعمل عليها
منذ عده ايام المبنى الذي ورائي هو مبنى
مكون من ثمانيه طوابق وكان يقتل في اثنان
عائله تمكنا من انقاذ شخصين
ومعظم المواطنين
المتواجدون في هذه المنطقه
طبعا مصابونها بالصدمه والالم والمعاناه
وطبعا
نتوقع ان
تستمر تستمر عمليات او تستمر الهزات
الارتزاديه امس شاهدنا هزتين ارضيتين او
زلزالين
بقوه
4.8.2 الوضع محزن للغايه ونحن نبذل قصارى
جهدنا
ونعمل على مدار الساعه ولكن للاسف
لا لن نستطيع ان نقوم بكل ما نريد ان
نحققه ذلك بسبب الدمار الفظيع الذي حدث
هذه بدايه قصه حزينه تتعلق
بالم
والضرر الذي اصاب البلد برمته نحن مشاركون
في العمل ونعرف ان الزلزال تسبب بكثير من
الالم
والمعاناه لتركيا وهذا امر لم نتوقعه ولكن
يمكن ان يحدث لنا في اي وقت من العام يعني
وفعلا السيده ساره المعاناه سواء في في
تركيا او في سوريا وعلى ذكر سوريا
الدفاع المدني هناك في سوريا اعلن عن
انتهاء مرحله البحث والانقاذ والمرور الان
الى مرحله البحث والانتشار بما يعني ذلك
تقريبا من فقدان الامل تقريبا بشكل شبه
نهائي من امكانيه العثور على على ناجين
سيده ساره اريد ان اسال عن مدى سهوله تحرك
فرق انقاذ اجنبيه في تركيا خاصه وان ربما
لابد من التنسيق مع الجهات التركيه
ذلك لان معظم المؤسسات الحكوميه
كانت تركز وبشكل فوري على المناطق التي
ضربتها او ضربها الزلزال الاول
وبالتالي كل المؤسسات وكل الجهات والهيئات
الحكوميه كانت تركز على منطقه واحده ثم
بعد ساعات
تعرضت المنطقه لزلزال اخر مدمر
وبالتالي
المناطق التي تضررت لاحقا لم تحصل على دعم
الكافي وما زال هنالك نقص في الخدمات وفي
الامدادات ومنها منطقه مناطئ وبالتالي
فان فرق وطواقم البحث والانقاذ التي اتت
من دول العالم
ركزت على المناطق التي تضررت جراء زلزال
الاول ونحن اتينا لنساعد في المنطقه التي
ضربها الزلزال الثاني هنا شكرا جزيلا لك
السيده ساره هديري رئيسه فريق الانقاذ
التابع لوزاره الدفاع الالبانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
وتتواصل في مدينه
نورداك بولايه غازي عنتاب التركيه عمليات
البحث عن ناجحه محتملين من تحت ركام
الزلزال تعد مدينه نورداغ الواقعه على بعد
اربعين كيلو متر من ولايه كهرمان مركز
الزلزال من اكثر المدن التركيه تضررا
مراسلنا عمر الحوراني وصل الى المدينه
ونقل جانبا من تداعيه زلزال هناك
مدينه نورداغ بولايه غازي عنتاب التركيه
حي بالكامل سوي بالارض
الذين كانوا مسافرين او صياحا باسماء
معلومه في فندق نورداغ صاروا مجهولين حتى
الان على الاقل
يرقدون تحت الانقط
لقد ضمر سجل اسمائهم معهم
قصدوا هذا الفندق عابرين للنوم مؤقتا
فشاء القدر ان يناموا طويلا
هل هناك احد الجميع يترقبون صوتا او انينا
مدينه النورداغ في حاله ماساويه هنا انقاذ
كثيره وفي كل مكان في نورداغ يوجد دمار
وان شاء الله يخرج الضحايا ونلتقي معهم
نحب في اقرب وقت
لا ينقطع الرجاء في انقاذ او انتشار مزيد
من الضحايا
على ناجينا من تحت الركم يستمر عمال
الانقاذ بالبحث لكن اين وكيف يقضي من كتب
لهم النجاه ليلتهم
جاء من ولايه اسطنبول وهذا ما يقدر عليه
التحدث مع المتضررين من الزلزال ومواساتهم
وحتى تقديم الحساء لهم يريحوا وجداننا
كثيرا كنا نتمنى ان نقدم لهم اكثر لكن هذا
ما نقدر عليه لا شيء سوى خيمه ونار تكسر
البروده وتمنيه النفس بان يكون اقربائهم
بخير
تكون واخرون تحت الانقاض انهارت بيوتنا
ولا نستطيع الدخول الى المباني
الزلزال دمر كل شيء وارتسم التفاصيل
الكارثه موجعه في الوجدان عمر الحوراني
الجزيره مدينه نورداغ جنوبيه تركيا
هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من ديار بكر
لاستمرار عمليات البحث والانقاذ الامل لم
يفقد بعد مثلما اشرنا بان الدفاع المدني
في شمال سوريا اعلن انتهاء مرحله
البحث
والانقاذ ومره الى مرحله البحث والانتشال
ولكن هذا لا يمنع من ان الجهود تظل مستمره
في اماكن اخرى مثل هذه الصور في ديار بكر
حيث يستمر الاهالي سواء الاهالي او الفرق
المختصه في البحث عن امكانيه البحث عن
ناشئين معنا الان من كهرمان مراش في جنوب
تركيا العقيد فيليبسون رئيس مؤسسه رجال
الاطفاء الدوليه لمواجهه الكوارث وقائد
فريق انقاذ فرنسي اهلا بك سيد
ما الذي قمتم به الى حد الان
[موسيقى]
وصلنا منذ يوم الثلاثاء في منطقه مراش بعد
الزل الهزه الثانيه
ومنذ وصولنا يوم الثلاثاء بدانا مع فرق
الانقاذ فورا
للبحث عن ضحايا في وسط مدينه مراش
وطلب منا التدخل باستخدام الكلاب
وفرق الانقاذ
وتمكنا من اخراج
بعض الموتى وعدد قليل من
الناجين وهناك عمليات مازال نقوم بها
لاخراج
شخص
وذلك بمساعده كلاب البحث
لديكم بالاساس مجموعه من الكلاب المدربه
ليست لديكم معدات ثقيله
لدينا معدات اتينا بها من فرنسا
ولدينا مجموعات متخصصه في البحث وتحديد
اماكن
الموجودين تحت الانقاض ولدينا ايضا معدات
الكترونيه
لمحاوله العثور وتحديد اماكنهم
ومعنا ايضا
مسيره طائره مسيره
وكذلك اليات لرفع
الانقاذ الثقيله
وللوصول الى الضحايا
لدينا ايضا فريق خاص
يسمح لنا باستخراج الضحايا عندما ننشر
اليها
شكرا جزيلا لك العقيد فيليب كنت معنا من
كهرمان مراش شكرا جزيلا لك
افاد مراسلنا بان الاف العائلات التي
تضررت من الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا تبيت
في العراء وسطا انخفاض حاد في درجات
الحراره وقد ناشدت منظمات سوريه الامم
المتحده وهيئات الاغاثه الدوليه من اجل
تامين الماوى والمرافق الخدميه والادويه
للمتضررين
منذ ان ضرب الزلزال بيوتها تفترش هذه
العائلات الارض وتلتحف السماء
همهم الوحيد تامين خيمه وبعض الاغطيه
تقيهم البرد القارس في ظل درجات حراره
تنخفض الى ما دون
خرجت ام محمد مع ابنائها واحفادها سالمين
من الزلزال
ومطالبها ليست كثيره
ندرك تحت ما في بالشمس عم ندبر حالنا بس
بالليل نحن ما في عنا شيء
بنفوت على بيوتنا لانه مشققه والتحذيرات
على الهواتف اني لا حدا يفوت على دور
المشققه وهيك
عشرات الاطفال تشل من تحت انقاض منازلهم
ادلب الشمالي يحتاجون الى الدفئ والرعايه
الطبيه والنفسيه
زلزال شمال غربي سوريا ينتظرون وصول
مساعدات عاجله تخفف عنهم تداعيات زلزال قد
تطول في منطقه تعاني اصلا من الفقر وندره
المساعدات
مساعدات امميه وصفت بالمتاخره والخجوله
دخلت من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا
وهي بحسب القائمين على المعبر ضمن اطار
برنامج الدعم الاعتيادي للنازحين اما فيما
يتعلق بالاستجابه الطارئه للزلزال فلن
تدخل اي معدات ثقيله تساعد في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ ولا اي المساعدات طبيه
دخلت قبل قليل قافله قادمه من الامم
المتحده مكونه من اربعه عشر شاحنه محمله
بمختلف المواد الاغاثيه لاغاثه اهلنا
المنكوبين جراء هذا الزلزال فيها مستلزمات
للقيام بطانيات واسفنجات وعوازل بالاضافه
لبعض السلل النظافه وبعض السلا الغذائيه
وحدها جثث الضحايا السوريين الذين قضوا في
زلزال كهرمان مارش كانت اسرع بالدخول الى
سوريا من فرق الانقاذ والمساعدات الطبيه
اكثر من 600 ضحيه دخلت من تركيا الى
الشمال السوري هم اللاجئون فروا من الموت
في سوريا
ليلقوه هناك ويعود دون تاشيره او جواز سفر
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره ريف ادلب الشمالي
ماساه اخرى تترافق مع الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا اذ اعلن برنامج الغذاء
العالمي ان مخزونه شمال غربي سوريا ينفد
البرنامج يحتاج عشرات الملايين من
الدولارات لمساعده مئات الاف المتضررين في
تركيا وسوريا
يعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان مخزونه
ينفد في شمال غرب سوريا ويدعو الى فتح
مزيد من المعابر الحدوديه من تركيا بعد
الزلزال ووجه البرنامج مناشده من اجل
الحصول على 77 مليون دولار لتقديم
المساعده لنحو
874 الف متضرر في تركيا وسوريا يشمل ذلك
284 الف نازح جديد في سوريا وخمسمائه الف
نازح في تركيا بينهم 45 الف سوري يشار الى
ان 90% من سكان شمال غرب سوريا البالغ
عددهم 4 ملايين واربعمائه الف شخص يعتمدون
على المساعدات الانسانيه يوفر البرنامج
المساعدات الغذائيه لاكثر من 4 ملايين شخص
في شمال غرب سوريا من بين نحو سته ملايين
ونصف مليون شخص يتلقون المساعدات من
البرنامج في جميع انحاء سوريا اما بالنسبه
لعد يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي في
سوريا قبل الزلزال فيقدره البرنامج باكثر
من 12 مليون شخص ويقدر عدد النازحين قبل
الزلزال بنحو سته ملايين وثمانمائه الف
شخص
وهذه الصور مره اخرى مباشره من ديار بكر
حيث لا تقل هذه المجموعات من بينهم مدنيين
ومن بينهم فرق اغاثه محترفين لا تقل ولا
تمل من محاوله العثور على ناجين رغم ان
هذه الامال
تتضاءل باستمرار طبعا نحن في نهايه اليوم
الخامس وبالتالي فالمساله ليست هينه على
الاطلاق
قال رائد الصالح رئيس منظمه الخوذه
البيضاء ان الامم المتحده ارتكبت جريمه
حقيقيه بحق الشعب السوري في شمال غرب
سوريا لانها لم ترسل حتى الان اي مساعدات
مرتبطه بالناجين من الزلزال نتعرف اكثر
على منظمه القوات البيضاء في هذه الورقه
كان قرار النظام السوري سحب الخدمات التي
تقدمها الدوله مثل الاطفاء والاسعاف
والرعايه الصحيه وصيانه شبكات المياه
والكهرباء عن المدن والاحياء الخارجه عن
سيطرته بالتزامن مع القصف العنيف لها
المحفز الاول لظهور مبادرات تطوعيه في تلك
المناطق لمحاوله ملء الفراغ والاستجابه
لنداءات الاستغاثه هناك وتقديم المساعدات
لمن يطلبها تبلورت المبادرات لاحقا لتنتظم
تحت مظلات اوسع وفي الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر 2014 اعلن عن توحدها تحت اسم الخوذ
البيضاء لتكون بمثابه الدفاع المدني في
المناطق الخارجيه عن سيطره النظام خلال
السنوات اللاحقه لذلك تقول المنظمه انها
نجحت في انقاذ حياه نحو 125 الف انسان من
تحت انقاض القصف والركام فقدت خلالها نحو
ثلاثمائه من افرادها خلال عملهم نصفهم في
ضربات استهد عمدا من قبل قوات النظام
وحلفائه كما يقول الموقع الرسمي للمنظمه
اعتمدت الخوذ البيضاء وما زالت على
المتطوعين والمتطوعات من مختلف المدن
السوريه ومن كافه فئات المجتمع ويعمل فيها
اليوم نحو ثلاثه الاف متطوع منذ فجر
السادس من فبراير الماضي وجدت منظمه
الخواد البيضاء نفسها امام كارثه غير
مسبوقه اذ كانت الخيار الاول والاخير
للملايين من السوريين القاطنين في شمال
البلاد
لانقاذهم من تداعيات زلزال هو الاعنف في
المنطقه منذ نحو قرن تقول المنظمه انها
سابقت الزمن لانقاذ العالقين تحت انقاض
المباني والمنازل المنهاره والاغاثه عشرات
الالاف من المنكوبين ممن شردهم الزلزال
رغم امكانياتها المحدوده والمتواضعه
وافتقارها الى المعدات والالات الثقيله
ومعنا من مدينه سرمدا الشماليه ادلب رائد
الصالح مدير الدفاع المدني السوري اهلا
وسهلا بك عندما نتحدث الان عن الانتهاء من
مرحله البحث
والانتقال الى مرحله البحث والانتشال
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالضبط
تحياتي لك وللساده المشاهدين حقيقه يعني
ذلك باننا فقدنا الامل تماما ان نجد اي
اشخاص احياء تحت الانقراض فننتقل الى
انتشال الجثث الموجوده تحت الانقاض وليقوم
لنقوم بتسليمها لاهلهم وهذا لذلك انا
تحدثت اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي واعتذرت
من شعبنا العظيم باننا اذا قصرنا ولكن قلت
لهم ايضا باننا بزلنا كل طاقتنا وبزلنا كل
جهدنا حتى نستطيع ان نصل الى كل الاشخاص
الاحياء ولكن يمكن ان قدراتنا الماديه
قدراتنا اللوجستيه قد خانتنا في بعض
اللحظات
وللاسف تجمدت الصوره من
سرمدا رائد صالح الذي هو مدير الدفاع
المدني وكان يشرح امكانيه او دلاله
الانتقال من مرحله البحث
والانقاذ الى مرحله البحث والانتشال وارجع
ذلك الى فقدان الامل في امكانيه العثور
على احياء للاسف الشديد وفي نفس الوقت
ايضا هناك
تقديم لاعتذار سبق له ان قاله في المؤتمر
الصحفي ولكن كرره الان
اعتذار للشعب السوري من ان فرق الانقاذ
حاولت قصاره جهدها ان تقدم ما تستطيع ولكن
واضح تماما ان الامكانيات اللوجستيه
والمعدات لم يكونا في مستوى الحدث
وبالتالي
الدفاع المدني السوري قام باقصى ما يمكنه
ولكن تلك هي حدود الامكانيات للاسف الشديد
هذا وقد دعى التسويسرا والبرازيل الى عقد
اجتماعي لمجلس الامن الدوليه لمناقشه
الاوضاع الانسانيه في سوريا في اقرب وقت
ممكن واكدت المندوبه السويسريه بالمجلس
باسكال كريستين بابيل السويلم في اجابه
على سؤال بشان ضروره ايصال المساعدات اكدت
ان بلادها والبرازيل على استعدادا لتسهيل
اتفاق على اجراءات اضافيه للمجلس اذا لزم
الامر لاغاثه المنكوبين
لقد دعونا لعقد اجتماع للمجلس بشان الوضع
الانساني في سوريا نريد ان نسمع من وكيل
الامين العام مارتن جريفيث في بدايه
الاسبوع المقبل بشان زيارته للمنطقه
بصفتنا الدولتين المعنيتين بالملف
الانساني فاننا على استعداد لتسهيل
الاتفاق على اجراءات اخرى من قبل المجلس
اذا لزم الامر
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيفاندو جريك انه لا ينبغي للعقوبات ان
تعوق ايصال المساعدات لمحتاجيها في سوريا
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره اضاف المتحدث
الاممي ان هناك مناقشات جاريه بين اعضاء
مجلس الامن للاسراعي في ارسال المساعدات
الى سوريا
من الواضح ان هناك منطقتين في سوريا
احداهما تابعه لسلطه الحكومه والاخرى غير
تابعه للحكومه هذا يمثل صعوبات وتحديات
اضافيه لنا لكننا نوصل المساعده الى
المنطقتين لدينا الان قافلتان عند معبر
باب الهوى في حلب للمناطق التي لا تقطع
لسيطره الحكومه تحمل معدات ماوى ومواد غير
غدائيه وسنرسل المزيد خلال هذا الاسبوع
ندعم كذلك جهود الحكومه السوريه في مناطق
سيطرتها بمساعده منظمه الصحه العالميه
وغيرها من المنظمات هناك مساعدات وصلت
سابقا ويجري توزيعها الان
من عم عمار عمار المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
منظمه اليونيسيف اهلا وسهلا بك سيد عمار
بالنسبه لكم كيونيسيف ما هو التحدي الابرز
في هذه الكارثه
[موسيقى]
طبعا الاستجابه بالمقام الاول كانت من
خلال المواد المتوفره لنا كنا نحن حطينا
بالبلد لحتى نستجيب اساسا للاحتياجات
الانسانيه قبل الزلزال والان عم نحسب كل
مواردنا لحتى كمان نسير طوافل وطائرات
لحتى نقدر نستجيب خاصه للاطفال يلي هن
معرضين بشكل اساسي للامراض وللخطر بعد بعد
مسار
فهذا بشكل اساسي وخاصه كمان اذا بدنا ننظر
الاحتياجات الاساسيه هي حاليا في مجال
التغطيه في مجال المياه الصالحه للشرب وفي
مجال حمايه الطفل اذا من ناخذ موضوع
المياه بشكل اساسي سوريا كانت عم تعاني من
كل الروب ما انتهى يعني كان من شهر سبتمبر
لاول السنه 84 الف حيله والاكثر بهذه
الكوليراكين من الاطفال وما زالت موجوده
والان الخوف الاكبر انه شبكات المياه هي
اللي هي دررت من بالزلزال المدمر بصير
فيها اختلاط مع مياه
وبالتالي ممكن تولد او بالعالم
الزلزالنا حاله وبائيه تؤثر على ملايين
الاشخاص وبالتالي
قدره المستشفيات على الاستجابه بكون كثير
صعب لانه اصلا كانت وضع كثير منهج في خلال
السنوات الماضيه وايضا استجابتها الاساسيه
الان هي ضحايا الزلزال والاصابات الناتجه
عن الزلزال موضوع التغذيه كمان موضوع ثاني
كثير مهم خاصه للاطفال تحت عمر السنتين
للنساء الحوامل اللي بدهم اهتمام خاص
وتغطيه خاصه لحتى كمان يقدروا يواجهوا
الظروف الصعبيه بعيشوا فيها اذا بتطلع هلا
نحن
بحلب في حمل طرطوس ادلب اكثر من اربعه
فاصله خمسه مليون شخص بحاجه لمساعده 100
المدارس تدمرت في شمال السوري كمان اكثر
من 4 مليون شخص كانوا بحاجه لمساعدات
انسانيه فالعدد مهول وبالتالي يجب كل
الاحتياجات
توصل للشعب السوري على قدر على قدر على
قدر الاحتياجات الموجوده عدد المساعدات
اللي عم توصل يجب ان تكون على قدر
الاحتياجات المطلوبه شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
سيدنا عمر المتحدث الاقليمي باسم منظمه
اليونسيف معنا من مدينه سرمدا الشماليه
ادلب رائد الصالح مدير الدفاع المدني الذي
غاب عنه قبل قليل عاد الينا لحسن الحظ
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد سيد رائد صالح كنت
تتحدث
للاسف فقد فقدناه
لنسال ونحاول ارجو ان تكون في الاستماع
سيد رائد صالح بالنسبه للانتقال كنت سالتك
عن مرحله الانتقال من البحث والانقاذ الى
مرحله البحث والانتشال واشرت الى ان ذلك
يعود الى فقدان الامل الان هذه المرحله
الجديده كيف ستكون
حقيقه يعني تسمعني نعم تفضل نعم
المرحله الثانيه هي ستكون في عمليه
الاستكمال عمليات بحث وانتشار الجثث والان
نحن ندقق مع الاهالي وندقق مع المدنيين
ونتحدث ايضا مع
الناجين من تحت الانقاب لنعلم عدد
الموجودين تحت الانقاض وستستمر عمليات
البحث
والانتشار وهي تستمر الان يعني نحن نتحدث
الان هناك فرق تعمل في جنديرس هناك فرق
تعمل في
سلقين في حارب ايضا تستمر في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ حتى نتاكد تماما بانه لم يبقى اي
شخص تحت الانقاض بعد هذه المرحله هناك
مرحله اخرى هي عمليه تقييم المباني
التي تضررت جراء الزلزال وازالتها اذا كان
هناك تشكل خطرا على المدنيين واذا كانت لا
تشكل خطرا فيت الاهالي للعوده الى منازلهم
التي تضررت المرحله الثالثه هي
المرحله الرابعه ستكون ازاله الانقاب من
الطرقات والمرحله الخامسه ان شاء الله اذا
استمرت الجهود واستمرت التمويل بشكل كافي
سيتم اعاده تاهيل البنيه التحتيه والطرقات
التي والصرف الصحي والمياه التي تضررت جرى
الزلزال
هناك عتاب شديد وخيبه امل من الامم
المتحده وصفتم بان ما ارتكبته في حق الشعب
السوري هو جريمه اذا سالناك ما الذي كان
بامكان الامم المتحده ان تقوم به حتى تكون
في مستوى الحدث
حقيقه يعني الجميع يعلم بان ضمن المؤسسات
الامم المتحده هناك مؤسسه معنيه بالبحث
والانقاذ اسمها انسيراج
اي تفضل تفضل واصل
هناك مؤسسه في الامم المتحده هي معنيه
بالبحث والانقاذ اسمها انسيراج هذه
المؤسسه هي
معنيه في الزلازل ومراقبه الكوارث هذه
المؤسسه هي التي توجه النداءات لكل جميع
المؤسسات
وفرق البحث والانقاذ الدولي لتتوجه الى
اماكن الزلازل هي تلقت الانذارات من سوريا
ومن تركيا لكن هي لم توجه انذارا فرق الى
شمال غرب سوريا وانما فقط وجهت فرق الى
تركيا طبعا انا لا الوم لا اقول انه لا
يجب تركيا هي بحاجه جدا الى فرق انقاذ
ولكن كان عليها ايضا ان ترسل الفرق بحث
وانقاذ الى شمال غرب سوريا وحقيقه انا
اليوم كنت اتحدث مع مسؤول في الامم
المتحده مسؤول سابق في الامم المتحده هو
صديق لي وقال لي هل مضت 72 ساعه ولم يتم
ارسال الفرق دولي للبحث قلت له هنا قال لي
هناك امر غريب في الامم المتحده يجب ان
تعلم ما هو ويجب ان تتسبح هذا الامر ولذلك
انا فعليا لم اخد على عاتقي فقط ان اعمل
مع فريقي لمساعده الناجين والمساعده
الضحايا ولتاهيل اعاده ترتيب بل اخذنا على
عاتقنا ايضا موضوع
العمل مع الدول ومع المؤسسات القانونيه
الدوليه سنعمل معها حتى نكتشف اين ظهر هذا
الخلل في مؤسسات الامم المتحده يجب عليها
ان تعتذر للشعب السوري ويجب عليها حقيقه
ان تتعامل بحياديه كما تدعي في عدا عن ذلك
المشكله الاهم
حقيقه انها تنشر معلومات مضلله عن هذا
الموضوع تنشر معلومات مضلله مثلا يعني
مثلا ثلاث يعني نعم مثلا ساذكر لك مثال
احد مسؤولين صرح قبل يومين بان فرق الدفاع
المدني طبعا هو لم يقل فرق الانقاذ في
شمال غرب سوريا وصلت فقط الى خمسه من
اماكن الزلزال وكنا في نفس الوقت نحن نعمل
بميه بالميه من المناطق التي
تضررت جراء الزلزال التصريح الاخر السيد
انطونيو الامين العام للامم المتحده صرح
بان الامم المتحده ارسلت مساعدات الى شمال
غرب سوريا وهذا التصحيح مضلل لان الامم
المتحده لم ترسل مساعدات لمواجهه الزلزال
وانما ارسلت مساعدات مجدوله هي مسبقا كانت
ستاتي الى اصحابها وهي اتت والسلامها
اصحابها هي ليست مساعدات مواجهه الزلزال
اضف الى ذلك قبل اليوم السيد روبير امين
الرئيس الصليب الاحمر الدولي ايضا صرح
بانه يعمل معك جميع السوريين في كل مناطق
وايضا هذا تصريح مضلل هو لا يعمل مع
السوريين الموجودين في شمال غرب سوريا
وانما يعمل فقط
وهو لا يقدم اي مساعدات في لشمال غرب
سوريا شكرا جزيلا لك رائد صالح مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري كنت معنا من مدينه
سرمدا الشماليه ادلب
نشر الزميل المصور في قناه الجزيره خالد
ليش فيديو يوثقوا لحظه وقوع الزلزال اثناء
وجود افراد من عائلته في منزلهم في مدينه
انطاكيا التركيه وهذا جانب جانب جانب مما
التقطته العدسه
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا رسول
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
[موسيقى]
وهذا راس الساعه وهذا تذكير بالعناوين
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وست مئه قتيل وسبعه
الاف جريح حتى الان جراء الزلزال في سوريا
الدفاع المدني في شمال البلاد يعلن
الانتهاء من مرحله البحث والانقاذ
والانتقال الى مرحله البحث والانتشال بسبب
اتساع الدمار وشحي معدات الانقاذ
المتحدث باسم الامن العام للامم المتحده
يقول للجزيره انه لا ينبغي للعقوبات ان
تعوق ايصال المساعده الى سوريا البيت
الابيض يؤكد ان العقوبات الامريكيه ليست
عائقا لدخول المساعدات والمدير العام
للصليب الاحمر ينفي للجزيره وجود فرق
للمنظمه في ادلب بعد اعلان النظام السوري
موافقته على ايصال المساعدات للمناطق
الخارجه عن سيطرته
بعد خمسه ايام على الزلزال فرق الانقاذ
تسابق الزمن بحثا عن ناجين تحت الانقاد في
المدن التركيه المنكوبه وعدد القتلى
يتجاوز 20 الفا ووزير الخارجيه التركيه
يقول للجزيره ان 13 مليون تركي تاثروا
بالزلزال وان اولويه الحكومه تكمن في
توفير احتياجاته
[موسيقى]
الان مباشره الى انقره وهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لنائب الرئيس التركي يستحقون الشكر
من اعماق قلبي
لدينا
المتبرعين قرابه
او
المتطوعين عفوا قرابه المئه وتسعه وخمسين
الف شخص من مختلف المؤسسات والمنظمات
المجتمع المدني يعملون على مساعده
المنكوبين
منهم طبعا من فقد افراد من اسرته هو
حقيقه ضمدوا جروحهم بشكل سريع واتوا
ليساعدوا
الاشخاص الاخرين تحت الانقاض
وحقيقه هذا اذا دل على ان الشعب التركي له
شخصيه فريده
وعندما يكون هناك طبعا محنه يواجهه يواجه
الشعب التركي هذه المحنه
واحده
ويقف وقفه واحده
طبعا هذا
اليوم طبعا الامم المتحده ارسلت لجنه
ومساعد
الامين العام للامم المتحده زار المنطقه
واثناء على جهود التي نقوم بها وقال بان
في تاريخ الامم المتحده لم نشهد حقيقه
زلزال بهذا الحجم وبهذا
الوسع الجغرافي
فانتم تقومون بتقديم
المساعدات والوصول لجميع هؤلاء الناس في
هذه المنطقه الكبيره وحقيقه تستحقون الشكر
والاشاده هذه جهود جباره وهو قال
ذلك
واثناء على الجهود
ونحن طبعا
وفرنا الخيم ووفرنا ايضا
المدفات الكهربائيه
وتركيا
واحده من الدول التي تحتوي على خيم اكبر
عدد من الخيم حول العالم
والان نقلنا كل
امكانياتنا وسخرناها في سبيل الوصول الى
المنكوبين اينما كانوا
ايضا
كل الشركات في تركيا المنتجه للخيام تعمل
بشكل مستمر
لانتاج المزيد من الخيم
لكي توفر
الخدمه والمساعده
للمنكوبين
نحن هدفنا هو نصل الى جميع المواطنين
الذين يحتاجون طبعا الماوى
في هذه المحنه وهنا ايضا اشكر جميع
العاملين
واشكر ايضا
المواطنين الذين
يصبرون علينا وعلى النواقص
واشكرهم طبعا باسم
رئيس الجمهوريه الذي ايضا يتابع هذه
العمليات عن قرب وعن كثب
ايضا
دائما نزوده بالمعلومات
وننقله ونعلمه
كل شيء على الفور شكرا جزيلا ممكن ان
نتلقى اسئله لو في اي سؤال
شكرا جزيلا
اذا كان هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي لنائب الرئيس التركي والذي
اكد فيه بالخصوص على العمل الدؤوب الذي
تقوم به مختلف الجهات للوصول الى
المنكوبين سواء بتوفير الخيم التي تعمل
الشركات على انتاجها بشكل مستمر او من
خلال
المدافع الكهربائيه للمحتاجين وغير ذلك من
الضروريات اللازمه في هذه الفتره
قال الدفاع المدني السوري انه تم الانتهاء
من عمليات البحث والانقاذ والانتقال
لمرحله البحث والانتشاد واوضح الدفاع
المدني السوري ان فرقه استنفدت كل الطاقات
المتاحه في عمليات البحث والانقاذ على
مدار الايام الخمسه الماضيه واضاف ان فرص
العثور على ناجين بدات تتضائل بعد مرور
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه على الزلزال بسبب
الانتشار الجغرافيه الكبير للدمار وشرح
المستلزمات والمعدات مشيرا الى انه لم يتم
انتشاله اي ناج من تحت الانقاد منذ صباح
يوم الخميس وعبر عن مقال انه احباط جديد
تجاه المجتمع الدولي الذي ترك السوريين
وحدهم في هذه الاوقات العصيبه
معنا من عساس في ريف حلب مراسل الجزيره
محمد الجزائري محمد اهلا بك من جديد
الانتقال الى مرحله البحث والانتشال
وتوقف البحث عن ناجين كيف يمكن ان يستقبل
ربما من قبل الاهالي هناك
حقيقه محمد هذا الخبر استقبله الاهالي
بالصدمه الكبيره
وخيبه الامال بالعثور على ذويهم الذين هم
عالق تحت الانقاذ وخصوصا في منطقه جنديرس
التي قال الدفاع المدني انه توقف عن البحث
والتنقيب عن الناجين في تلك المنطقه وبدا
بعمليه البحث والانتشال اي انه فقد الامل
بالكامل من العثور على الناجين تحت هذه
القائد وبهذه هذا التصريح اي ان هناك
عمليات العمليات الدفاع المدني ستتغير من
البحث
والتنقيب شيئا فشيئا
بادوات وبدقه عن الناجين تحت الانقاض الى
عمليات ربما تكون
بالالياف الثقيله تفريغ المناطق المدمره
والنقل
الركام والبحث عن جثث القتلى والذين فقدوا
حياتهم تحت هذه حقيقه هناك حاله حاله
ماساويه لدى الذين الاهالي الذين فقدوا
ذويهم وما زالوا تحت الانقاذ اذويهم تحت
من اعداد المفقودين هناك خيبه امال كبيره
ليس بالفرق الدفاع المدني انما بتجاوب
المجتمع الدولي مع هذه الكارثه وعدم
المساهمه بمساعدات لوجستيه او بفرق انقاذ
للعمل في تلك المنطقه والبحث عن الناجين
حقيقه كما ذكرت ان اخر عمليه
انقاذ كانت لاشخاص
نجوا من تحتها هذه الركاب وخرجوا على قيد
الحياه هي كانت منذ قرابه الاثنين وعشرين
ساعه اي صباح اليوم اي صباح صباح الخميس
حقيقه صباح الجمعه
صراحه الواقع الانساني جدا بات صعب الواقع
لدى الاعمال الناس جدا صعب
منازلهم لم يعد لديهم ماوى الذين تصدعت
منازلهم وباتت غير قابل للسكن لم يعد
لديهم امل في العوده الى مازن انما يبحثون
عن امل جديد او عن حياه جديده قد تكون
مليئه بالاعباء مليئه بالماساه مليئه
بالمشقه ربما الذين فقدوا منازلهم وهم
اعدادهم كبيره جدا يخرجون الى مراكز
ومؤقتاه كهذه التي هي خلف قيام انشاها
متطوعون يقيمون فيها عده ايام وثم ينتقلون
الى خيام الى مخيمات انشاتها منظمات محليه
لاستقبال الذين تبرج هذا الزلزال او الى
منازل ذويهم
ليدرسوا بعدها الى اين المصير هذه
الانتقال من الحياه في المنازل والمدن الى
الحياه في المخيمات هي صعبه جدا على
الاهالي فالحياه في مخيمات هي اساسا صعبه
واساسا المخيمات تفتقر الى ابسط مقومات
الحياه
تفتقي الخدمات الصحيه و الاساسيه تعيشا
اوضاعا صعبه ان كان في فصل الشتاء ان كان
في فصل الصيف هذه النقاط المتوقف عند هذه
النقطه النقاط الاقامه المؤقته كهذه الذي
هي خلفيه يقيم فيها عدد كبير من السكان
هذه الخيام
بالحجم الكبير يقيم فيها حاليا النساء
والاطفال العائلات التي توافدت الى هذه
النقطه بامكان من مدينه الاقارب او سرمدا
او الدانه او
اطراف مدينه عفرين والقرى هنيك توافد الى
هذه النقاط هذه احدى النقاط النساء
والاطفال يقيمون داخل هذه القيام بينما
الرجال يبقون خارج القيام حتى ساعات
متاخره خلال ساعه الليل يقيمه يقومون
باشعال بعض الاطارات او بعض الاخشاب
للتدفئه اما عندما بزوغ الفجر وفي ساعه
الصباح يقوم النساء بانتقال الى خيمه
وتفريغ احدى القيام لتلقى هؤلاء الشباب
والرجال قسطا من من الراحه هناك شكوى
وهناك ضعاف في الامكانيات من قبل المنظمات
المحليات لما تقدمه لهؤلاء الذين تضرروا
هناك ماساه كبيره جدا بالمقابل هناك
امكانيات محدوده من قبل المنظمات
الانسانيه تحاول تقديم المساعدات من كان
المساعدات الغذائيه الوجبات الغذائيه
الاغذيه
بعض المواد الغذائيه والتموينيه ولكن هناك
ضعف في التامين المواد الطبيه في مستلزمات
طبيه فهناك مرضى وهناك ذوي اعاقه في هذه
النقاط يحتاجون الادويه بشكل مستمر
ويحتاجون
علاج بشكل مستمر هذا يفتقره
تفتقره هذه النقاط حقيقه بينما الاهالي
الذين جلسنا معهم وسالناهم وتحدثنا معهم
يجدون صعوبه حتى في تامين خيام من تصنيع
المحليه المصنعه في المناطق المحليه
لتكلفتها العاليه ربما تصل الى اكثر من
200 دولار اضافه الى مستلزمات لربما
اساسيات سيعيشون فيها ذائقه هذه القيمه
وقد تصل ايضا الى اكثر مئتين دولار ايا
نحن نتحدث عن مبلغ 400 دولار لعائلات
منكوبه فقدت كل ما تملكه في منازلها وبدات
من الصفر حياه جديده مليئه بالصعوبات
والمشقه اليك محمد شكرا جزيلا لك محمد
الجزائري من عزاز في حلب شكرا لك
اذا كما اسلفنا قال الدفاع المدني السوري
انه تم الانتهاء من عمليات البحث والانقاذ
والانتقال الان لمرحله البحث
والانتشار واوضح الدفاع المدني السوري ان
فرقه استنفذت كل الطاقات المتاحه في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ على مدار الايام
الخمسه الماضيه واضاف ان فرص العثور على
ناجين بدات تتضائل بعد مرور اثنتين وسبعين
ساعه على الزلزال بسبب الانتشار الجغرافي
الكبير للدمار وشح المستلزمات والمعدات
فقدنا الامل تماما ان نجد اي اشخاص احياء
تحت الانقراض فننتقل الى انتشال الجثث
الموجوده تحت الانقاض وليقوم لنقوم
بتسليمها لاهلهم وهذا لذلك انا تحدثت
اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي واعتذرت
من شعبنا العظيم باننا اذا قصرنا ولكن قلت
لهم ايضا باننا بزلنا كل طاقتنا وبزلنا كل
جهدنا حتى نستطيع ان نصل الى كل الاشخاص
الاحياء ولكن يمكن ان قدراتنا الماديه
قدراتنا اللوجستيه قد خانتنا في بعض
اللحظات
ولكن في تركيا هناك استنفار كامل لاجهزه
الدوله لمواجهه اثار الزلزال الذي حول
اجزاء كثيره من المحافظات العشر المتضرره
الى مناطق منكوبه في العرض التالي نرصد
جوانب من حجم التعبئه لمواجهه هذه الكارثه
[موسيقى]
معنا من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر
ابو نبوت منتصر قبل قليل تبعنا المؤتمر
الصحفي لنائب الرئيس التركي وتحدث عن
تكثيف الوصول الى المنكوبين كما سماهم
سواء من حيث الخيم والشركات الخاصه
والمصانع ستنتج المزيد منها دون توقف
وكذلك المدافع الكهربائيه وغير ذلك هل
تعتقد بان هذا
سيخفف من مصاب الكثيرين هناك
حقيقه محمد نعم قد يخفف لان المصاب قد وقع
ولكن الان هناك معاناه يعيشها جميع
الاهالي الذين نزلوا الى الشوارع والى
الساحات مدينه عنتاب وكغيرها من المدن
التي تعرضت لهذا الزلزال سواء في سوريا او
في تركيا لا تزال تواجه تداعيات هذا
الزلزال وهناك الالاف كما ذكرت من الاهالي
في الشوارع وفي الساحات ايضا وزير الاسكان
كانت في اليوم في مدينه غازي عنتاب وتجول
مع رئيس بلديه غازي عنتاب فاطمه شاهين
وتحدث عن 15 الف خيمه قد نصبت في مدينه
غازي عنتاب وحدها في عده نقاط منها هذه
النقطه وهي احدى الحدائق في مدينه غازي
عنتاب يمكننا ان نشاهد الان حال الاشخاص
الذين هربوا الان يعني انتقلوا من المنازل
الى هذه الخيام كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
ذهبوا الى الى هذه القيام يعني بحثا عن
الدفئ طبعا ليس
جميع من متمكن الجميع لم يتمكنوا من
الحصول على القيام لان هذا الامر يحتاج
الى وقت وايضا هذا ما صرح به وزير الاسكان
التركي الذي قال ان هناك ايضا نحو 500 بيت
متنقل ايضا في مدينه غازي عنتاب وايضا قال
ان هذا العدد سيرتفع في محاوله تكفي جميع
الاشخاص المنكوبين والاشخاص غير المنكوبين
الان الاهالي يخافون ان يعودوا الى
منازلهم والحديث عن العوده الى المنازل
بلديه غازي عنتاب تحدثت عن نحو 500 عامل
متخصص في متخصص في الابنيه سيقومون بزياره
لاغرب او لكافه الابنيه في مدينه غازي
عنتاب لتحديد مستوى الدمار وتحديد ما اذا
كانت هذه الامنيه ستكون بحاجه الى
ترميم او انها صالحه للعيش فورا او انها
ستكون يعني سيتم هدمها وليست صالحه للعيش
وذلك يعني حفاظا على حياه الناس وقد قصصت
في موقعا اطلقت موقع الكترونيا يمكن لاي
شخص ان يدخل اليه ويحدد عنوان منزله
والبناء الذي يعيش فيه سيجد اذا كان هذا
المنزل ما تم فحصه ام لا وايضا تحدثت
فاطمه شاهين عن
نحو 500 الف وجبه يتم توزيعها يوميا في
هذه المناطق وحدثت ايضا النقاط اخرى يتم
توزيع فيها وجبات ساخنه يوميا للاشخاص
المتضررين يمكننا الان ان يعني نجول في
هذا المخيم ونحاول ان نلتقي قبل قليل كنا
شاهدنا بعض الاشخاص يجلسون هنا يقيدون
النيران وهم يعني يحاولون ان يعني
يحصلوا على بعض الدفع من خلال لقاء
النيران نحن درجات الحراره منخفضه متدنيه
منذ ايام سنحاول السلام عليكم وعليكم
حضرتك في هذه الخيمه
هل حصلت على الخيمه بعد ما حصلت عليه هل
تغير الظرف بالنسبه لكم هل الان انتم يعني
تحسنت احوالكم
هل تضرر منزلك خلال هذا
عائلتك موجوده داخل
مركز دافئ
سنحاول ان ندخل الى هذه الخيمه لنرى نعم
زميل مصور يمكن ان يدخل ايضا الى الخيمه
من الداخل
هذه الخيمه من الداخل يعني هي محاوله لرصد
واقع الحال والعيش بالنسبه
للهاربين من هذا الزلزال الذي يعني هذه
الخيمه هي قد تقيهم بالفعل من بعض البرد
لكن نحن نتحدث عن عن وضع يعني نتحدث عن
موضوع ماساوي في هذه المنطقه والجميع هنا
يحاول ان يؤمن مصدر دفء اما بوسائل خاصه
بالنسبه له لان اغلب الاشخاص لديهم منازل
في هذه المنطقه فيذهبون الى منازلهم
للحصول على بعض بشكل سريع ياخذ بعض
الحاجات الاساسيه المتعلقه بالتدفئه ومنهم
من ينتظر تقديم المساعده من قبل المنظمات
الحكومه التركيه والسلطات المحليه التي
تحاول وتسعى جاهده لكنها نحن لا نتحدث عن
منطقه واحده قد ضربت او نتحدث عن بناء نحن
نتحدث عن مدن باكملها بالاضافه الى ان
هناك تخوف من العوده وله هنالك عدد كبير
من الاشخاص يجلسون في سياراتهم مع
عائلاتهم منذ ان ضرب هذا الزلزال مدينه
غازي عنتاب وايضا هنالك اخرين ذهبوا الى
خارج مدينه غازي عنتاب على طرقات الرئيسيه
بعيدا عن الابنيه مثل هذه الخيام الموجوده
هناك كما نشاهد هي تكون بعيده عن الابنيه
في حال لو ان الزلزال قد تكرر او جاءت اي
ضربات اي ضربات ارتداديه وسقطت اي ابنيه
لا يتاذى احد ولا يكون يعني هناك خطر على
حياتهم شكرا لك منتصر ابو نبوت من غازي
عنتاب وكان الله في عون
الناس في تلك المناطق شكرا لك الان معنا
من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراسلنا
مراد هاشم مراد واضح نبره الغضب والاستياء
لدى السوريين من الامم المتحده ولكن هناك
في نيويورك كيف يتحدثون عن هذا الموضوع
بالفعل محمد وهذا ما طرحته تحديدا على
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
وهو رده بان الامم المتحده كانت استجابتها
سريعه
لتداعيات هذه الكارثه وفور وقوعها مشيرا
الى انه قد تكون هناك بعض الالتباسات لان
الكثير من شاحنات المساعدات التي تصل الى
المناطق السوريه لا تحمل شعار الامم
المتحده واجمالا ما تقوله المنظمه بهذا
الشان انها اعتمدت في الواقع بعد حدوث
الزلزال على ما كان يتوفر لديها في
مخازنها في تلك المنطقه من مساعدات
لتوزيعها على المتضررين من الكارثه وانها
ليست مؤهله للقيام بع البحث والانقاذ وان
انها لا تملك الامكانات للقيام بهذه بهذه
المهمه وان كانت تقوم بعمليه التنسيق بين
فرق الانقاذ فيما يتعلق بالجانب التركي
هناك 57 فرقه انقاذ دوليه نسقت بينها
الامم المتحده وهناك فريق في هذه المساله
يتجه الى سوريا ان لم يكن قد وصل تحديدا
الهدف حلب واللاذقيه في المجمل الانتقادات
تطال ايضا مجلس الامن الدولي وردا على ذلك
سفيره البرازيل وسويسرا قال انه من السهل
التوجيه الانتقاد لمجلس الامن الدولي لكن
المجلس بطبيعه الحال الذي لم يعقد حتى
الان اي جلسه بهذا بشان هذه الكارثه كما
قال تحديدا ان السفير البرازيلي المجلس
يحتاج الى معلومات موثقه ولا يمكنه
الاستناد الى تقارير وكالات
الاعلام بطبيعه الحال هو ينتظر كما قال
الانتهاء مارتن جرافيت من مهمته وزيارته
التقييميه في ضوء ذلك سيتحرك المجلس لعقد
جلسه بالفعل هناك قرار بعقدها ولكن حاله
تمكن المجلس من سماع احاطه التي قد لا
تكون بحضور الشخصي ولكن قد تكون من
المنطقه بعد انتهاء
مهمين مهمه بطبيعه الحال هذه المهمه لا
تشمل فقط التقييم ولكن كما علمنا من مصادر
الدبلوماسيه ايضا يسعى الاقناع نظام
السوري
برفع التحفظاته وممانعته لادخال مساعدات
الى المناطق التي لا يسيطر عليها عبر
الحدود
اذا سمحت النظام بذلك فان فانه وفقا لمصدر
دبلوماسي لن تكون هناك حاجه لاصدار قرار
من مجلس الامن الدولي لاعتماد منفذ او
منافذ اضافيه لكن حتى الان وحتى هذه
اللحظه ورغم ما اعلن من النظام اليوم عن
انه سمح بايصال المساعدات الى كافه مناطق
سوريا حتى بما في ذلك التي لا تخضع
لسيطرته فان نظام لا يزال يمانع في هذه
المساله المصدر الدبلوماسي قال انه حتى في
حال موافقه النظام قد تكون هناك تحفظات
روسيه ايضا لدواعي امنيه بمساله دخول
المساعدات ولكن هناك ايضا من ضمن التوجهات
في حاله استمرت ممانعه النظام السوري فان
من ضمن الخيارات هو اللجوء الى قرار تحت
الفصل السابع من اجل ادخال المساعدات
بمعزل عن موافقه النظام من رفضه في المجمل
ما تحاول الامم المتحده ان توصل له ردا
حتى على هذه الانتقادات والاعلانات
المتباينه والمختلفه والمتعدده من مختلف
وكالاتها
البرنامج الغذاء العالمي اليونيسيف الصحه
العالميه المجلس الامم المتحده للسكان
وغيره ومكتب تنسيق من مساعدات وبالارقام
وزعت خلال فتره الايام الاربعه الماضيه
على سبيل المثال برنامج الغذاء العالمي
اعلن انه وزع مساعدات خلال الايام الماضيه
ومنذ بدء الزلزال
لاكثر من
115 الف شخص في سوريا وفي تركيا علما ان
المخزونات كانت في المتوفره في شمال شرق
غرب سوريا تزيد على مساعده تكفي لمئه الف
شخص لاسبوع فقط محمد شكرا لك مراد هاشم من
نيويورك
الان من اسطنبول للسيده ديمركان نائبه
مدير منظمه تركيا اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي ما
تقديركم للموقف الان في تركيا
انقاذها من خلال عمليات البحث والانقاذ
وفي هذه الاثناء الناجون في الله في
العراء في البرد لا يريدون العوده الى
منازلهم حيث حتى تلك التي لم تدمرهم
تابعونا في سيارتهم او في الخيام او
التحقوا بافراد عائلاتهم واقاربهم في
مناطق اخرى ولكن الذين بقوا في المدينه
هم في العراق في الخارج واعتقد انه انا
الاوان ليحصلوا على الماوى الذي يحتاجون
اليه لانه لان الفصل هو فصل الشتاء والطقس
بارد جدا
وبالتالي يجب ان نوفر لهم الماوى في اسرع
وقت ممكن حاله الطوارئ التي اعلنت في
تركيا الا تساعد في ترتيب هذا الموضوع
بشكل اسرع بكثير
ربما توفر بعض الدعم لتحقيق هذا الهدف
ولكننا نعتقد ان حجم الدمار هو هائل جدا
وبالتالي فان دوله عليها ان تعمل معا
وبمشاركه المجتمع المدني وبالتالي نحن في
منظمه اوكس فام واتحاد اوكسف عام نحن جزء
من منظومه الاستجابه والتي تضم عشرات
المنظمات غير الحكوميه او منظمات المجتمع
المدني في تركيا وفي منطقه الكوارث نحن
نعمل ونقوم بدعم عمليات البحث والانقاذ
وكذلك نعمل على الدعم العمليات الاخرى
وذلك من اجل التامات التاكد من تربيه
الحجازات الطارئه للناس وكذلك تقديم
الخدمات للناس سيمه تلك التي هم فيها مس
الحاجه لها وهل التنسيق بين كل هذه
المنظمات يسير بشكل جيد
نعم بالتاكيد هنالك بعض التاخير سيما في
التنسيق هنالك بعض المشاكل والتحديات التي
نواجهها بين الحين والاخر ولكن هذا طبعا
متوقع في كارثه بهذا الحجم
هذه من اكبر الكوارث التي شهدتها تركيا
وعايشتها خلال القرن الماضي ولكم ان
تتخيلوا ان الامور ليست سهله سيما فيما
يتعلق بالتنسيق فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق بين
الجهود وتربيه الاحتياجات ناموا لك بعض
المشاكل الاشكاليات التي تتعلق بين تنسيق
بين المنظمات وكذلك فيما يتعلق بتوزيع
المعونات ولكن الهيئات الحكوميه والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه تعمل وبشكل النشط في الميدان
وذلك للتاكد من الوصول الى الجميع وان
جميع الناجين سيحصلون على احتياجات التي
يحتاجونها هل من السائل من السهل اخذ
عائلات باكملها ربما من المدن المتضرره
الى مدن اخرى الى الفنادق الى المدارس او
غيرها من المنشات في مدن اخرى مثل ما اشار
الرئيس التركي في اكثر من مره
انتقلت الى مدن اخرى اذا كان لديهم اقارب
او معارف وبالتالي هم انتقلوا الى المدن
المجاوره وكذلك تلك المدن وفرت الفنادق
ووفرت المنشات
والملاجئ الاخرى
ووفرتها للناس الذين يريدون ان ينتقلوا
ويرتحلوا الى تلك
المدن ولكن هناك عائلات كثيره فضلت البقاء
في مدنها وفي بلداتها
ولذلك حرصنا على ان نوفر لهؤلاء الناس
الذين ارتاوا البقاء في مدنهم
الماوى والاحتياجات والخدمات التي يحتاجون
اليها ولذلك من الاهميه بمكان ان تقوم
الجهات المزوده للخدمات توفير هذه
الاحتياجات للسكان والمواطنين في المناطق
التي تضررت شكرا جزيلا لك سيده ادم ديمرك
نائبه مدير منظمه اوكسفان تركيا كنت معنا
من اسطنبول شكرا لك
مع مضي اكثر من مئه ساعه وتضاؤل الامل في
وجود ناجين بدات تفاصيل انقاذ جديده تحكي
ما هو اقرب للمعجزات
في هاتايم انتشرت ربيعه
البالغه من العمر 27 عاما من تحت الانقاض
والركام بعد 120 ساعات وكانما يتحدى واقع
الحال واصرار المنقذين مختلف الهمسات التي
تتحدثه عن تراجع فرص العثور على ناجين
وقالوا سمعنا سمعنا
[موسيقى]
وهنا في كهرمان مرعش انقذت الفرق العامله
رجلا ظل محاصرا تحت انقاذ الزلزال لمده
140 ساعات يتلو الرجل ايات من القران
الكريم بينما يجري نقله
تروي الصور تفاصيل مذهله اخرى وكانما
التمسك بالامل يهزم مختلف العبارات التي
تفقي بضعف احتمالات العثور على ناجين
ويلهم فرق الانقاذ التي تعمل في ظروف
بالغه التعقيد في المضي قدما بحثا عن اي
حياه تخرج بين الانقاض المميته
بولايه هاتاي قصص اخرى فقد نجح عمال
الانقاذ في تحرير زينب كهرمان البالغ من
العمر 40 عاما وقد ظلت محتجزه ايضا مئه
واربع ساعات كاد الياس خلالها يتملك
المحيطين بها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وعلى الرغم من مرور اكثر من مئه ساعه من
وقوع الزلزال المدمر تواصل فرق الانقاذ
مسابقه الزمن بحثا عن ناجين وحتى عن ضحايا
ما زالت تحاصرهم الالقاب
صحيح ان احتمال العثور على احياء بعد هذه
المده قد يكون استثنائيا لكنه ليس بمستحيل
هذا وتتواصل في مدينه غازي عنتاب التركيه
عمليات البحث عن ناجين محتملين من تحت
ركام الزلزال
مدينه الواقعه على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا
من ولايه كهرمان مراش مركز الزلزال من
اكثر المدن التركيه تضررا مراسلنا عمر
الحوراني وصل الى المدينه ونقل جانبا من
تداعيات الحدث
مدينه نورداغ بولايه غازي عنتاب التركيه
حي بالكامل سوي بالارض
الذين كانوا مسافرين او سياحا باسماء
معلومه في فندق نورداغ صاروا مجهولين حتى
الان على الاقل
يرقدون تحت الانقط
لقد ضمير سجل اسمائهم معه
قصدوا هذا الفندق عابرين للنوم مؤقتا
فشا القدر ان يناموا طويلا
هل هناك احد الجميع يترقب صوتا او انينا
نرضى
مدينه نورداغ في حاله ماساويه هنا انقاض
كثيره وفي كل مكان في يوجد دمار وان شاء
الله يخرج الضحايا ونلتقي مع من نحب في
اقرب وقت
لا ينقطع الرجاء في انقاذ او انتشال مزيد
من الضحايا
على الرغم من تضاؤلي فرص العثور على
ناجينا من تحت الركم يستمر عمال الانقاذ
بالبحث لكن اين وكيف يقضي من كتب لهم
النجاه ليلتهم
جاء من ولايه اسطنبول وهذا ما يقدر عليه
التحدث مع المتضررين من الزلزال ومواساتهم
وحتى تقديم الحساء لهم يريح وجداننا كثيرا
كنا نتمنى ان نقدم لهم اكثر لكن هذا ما
نقدر عليه لا شيء سوى خيمه ونار تكسر
البروده وتمنيه النفس بان يكون اقربائهم
بخير
عندنا اقرباء مختفون واخرون تحت الانقاض
انهارت بيوتنا ولا نستطيع الدخول الى
المباني
الزلزال دمر كل شيء وارتسم التفاصيل
الكارثه موجعه في الوجدان عمر الحوراني
الجزيره مدينه نورداغ جنوبيه تركيا
معنى الان من اسطنبول شامل مدير منظمه
خبيبه التركيه للاغاثه الانسانيه اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدي يلدرم الان بعد كل ما جرى
ما هي المهمه الاساسيه التي يجب التركيز
عليها
يعني حاليا في مناطق الكوارث الحمد لله
وصل الكثير من المساعدات ولكن هذه
المساعدات مؤقته لان الناس المتطورين
اجتمعوا البضائف ارسلوه انفسهم الى مناطق
الكوارث ولكن هذه سينتهي بعد فتره اكثر
شيء ثلاثه اربع ايام سيستمر فبعده سيبقى
في المنطقه فقد منظمات فالحكومه حتى يساعد
الناس لان الكارثه سيستمر على الاقل سنه
فالناس يبقى ان يبنوا بيوتهم عند المخيمات
لاجله نحن حاليا كجمعيه الخبيب اوقفنا
ارسال المساعدات حتى ينتهي مساعدات
الموجوده هناك لان الحمد لله تركم كثير من
المساعدات في المناطق في هاتاي في كهرمان
مرعش وفي
مدن الاوكر فقد حاليا في مشكله عند شمال
السوريه
فارسلنا بعض البضائع شمال السوريه لان مع
الاسف فقد يدخل الى شمال السوريه منظمه
الهيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
لان جميع المنظمات التركيه تركز على مدن
التركيه لانهم يذهبوا ويدخل الى داخل
سوريا سيجتمعون الانتقادات كبيره
لاجلهم نحن ندعو الشعب السوري واخواننا
العرب ان يهتموا بشمال سوريا بشكل كبير
فيرسل المساعدات الى شمال السوريه خاصه
لان مع الاسف حتى الان فقد استطعنا ان
نرسل مساعدات قليله الى شمال السوريه اكثر
المساعدات حاليا يتركز الى مدن التركيه
قد يكون هذا مفهوم التركيز على المدن
التركيه ولكن اشرت قبل قليل الى ان ما وصل
من خبيب ومن غيرها
مساعدات تكفي في الوقت الحالي ولكن مع ذلك
ما زلنا نرى الناس
تشتكي وتطالب بالمزيد من المساعدات
يعني المساعدات سيستمر طبعا لان اكثر
مساعدات التي من خارج تركيا لم يصل بعد
يعني فقد وصل ثلاثه اربعه طائرات ليست
مساعدات الحقيقيه مثلا نحن كجمعيه الخبيب
عندنا حروب في
باكسترا في بريطانيا نحن استطعنا ان نجمع
فلوس ولكن لم نستطيع ان نحاول بعد لان
الامور الرسميه يستغرق وقت ولكن حاليا
البضائع الذي وصل الى المنطقه تقريبا 99%
من الاتراك
بضائع الاتراك سينتهي قريبا
فالاحتياجات سيبقى على طول السنه على
الاقل لان الناس كما قلت قبل قليل
يجلسون طول سنه في مخيمات ليس في المباني
فحينما تجلس في المخيمات حتى في مواسم
الشتاء هذا صعب جدا يعني مثلا نحن دخلنا
الى بعض الخيم
باقي البقاء في الخيام صعبه جدا بارده
خاصه في الشتاء فلا يمكن ان يدفعه الناس
بالنار او بالتدفئه اخرى لان لا يوجد في
المناطق كما تعلمون كهرباء حاليا لان اذا
حكومه اعطى الكهرباء في مناطق الكوارث
سيسبب مشاكل كبير للناس الذي
موقوفين تحت الانقاض لان حاليا الناس ما
زال يخرج تحت الانقاض الحمد لله فاذا يعطي
الحكومه
الكهرباء الى المدينه يمكن ان يضر به
الناس الموقوفين او الناس الذي يحاول ان
يخرجوا الناس
فكهرباء على الاقل سيصل الى المدينه بعد
فتره وفي هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي مدفاه ولا
اي تدفئه في المنطقه فلا يمكن ان نستخدم
اي شيء شكرا لك سيد شامل مدير منظمه خبيب
التركيه للاغاثه الانسانيه شكرا جزيلا
نعود الى اعلان الدفاع المدني السوريه انه
تم الانتهاء من عمليات البحث والانقاذ
والانتقال الى مرحله البحث والانتشال
انضموا الينا من ادلب حميد خطينه المتطوع
في الدفاع المدني السوري اهلا وسهلا بك
عمليا تطبيق هذا الانتقال كيف سنراه في
الايام المقبله
بعد مرور اكثر من 100 ساعه او 110 ساعات
على عمل الزلزال وعمليات البحث والانقاذ
الحسر الامل لوجود ناس ومدنيين واطفال على
قيد الحياه تحت انقاذ المباني المدمره
الان من اكثر من 24 ساعه فرقنا
اقتصرت عملياتها على انتشال المتوفين من
تحت انقاض منازل المدمره بمناطق
من ريف ادلب وحلب
المرحله الان هلق نحن فيها هي مرحله البحث
عن الجثث المتوفين وانتشالهم من تحت
الانقاض وتسليمهم لذويهم ودفنهم
هل ستكون هذه العمليه سهله خاصه في غياب
معدات ثقيله
للدفاع المدني السوري
ان تكون سهله كما المرحله التي سبقتها
مرحله البحث والانقاذ وهي المرحله الاهم
كانت
خلال الفتره كلها نحنا عم نرسل نداءات
الاستغاثه للعالم كله عم نطلب
معدات على امل نتمكن من انقاذ اناس عايشين
على قيد الحياه لكن للاسف مع مرور الفتره
الذهبيه بفرصه انقاذ المدنيين ولحتى اليوم
ما راح ندخل باليوم السادس على الزلزال لم
يتم وصول اي مساعدات تساعد فرقنا على
عمليات البحث والانقاذ سواء كانت لوجستيه
او تقنيه او بالاليات
الثقيله وبالروافه
هل هناك على الاقل وعود او مؤشرات اوليه
لامكانيه وصول مثل هذه المعدات في الايام
القريبه المقبله
نعم هناك وعودات من وعود من عده جهات هذه
المساعدات التي سوف تصل في المرحله
القادمه راح يكون
راح تساعد لكن راح تساعد مو مرحله الانقاذ
راح تساعد بالمراحل الجايه هي مثل ما قلت
مراحل انتشال جثث المتوفين من تحت الانقاذ
مرحله ازاله الركام مراحل
ازاله الاسطح او الجدران الايه للسقوط
والعدد اليوم بالالاف بالاضافه الى تامين
الابنيه المتصدعه
هؤلاء المنكوبين الذين الان
يقضون الليل خارج بيوتهم بطبيعه الحال كيف
تتعاملون مع حالاتهم
نعم
مئات الالاف من المدنيين المشردين اليوم
بمناطق من ريف ادلب وحلب خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه حتى اللحظه ما وقفت بالاضافه
للمتصدعه بيوتون بالاضافه لمن نجوا من تحت
انقاذ منازل
الظروف صعبه كتير عم يعيشوها في بعض نقاط
الايواء اللي تم تجهيزها من قبل منظمات
محليه هون بمناطق شمال غرب سوريا ظروف
صعبه كتير عندهم بالنسبه لفرقنا عم تحاول
بامكانياتها البسيطه تقديم بعض الرعايه
الصحيه
للمتضررين بالاضافه الى جولات لتقييم
الوضع والاحتياج
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد حميد قطين المتطوع
بالدفاع المدني السوري من ادلب شكرا
لمساهمتك
هذا وتجد فرق الانقاذ نفسها في سباقا مع
الزمن للوصول الى اكبر عدد من الناجين
باعتبار عامل الوقت هو عامل حاسم وتتضائل
مع مروره فرص انقاذ عالقين تحت الانقاد
ويبقى تحديد موعدا لوقف عمليات الانقاذ
بدوره حساسا وصعبا ويخدع بظروف وعوامل
عديده
قبل 13 عاما عاشت هايتي زلزالا مدمرا
تجاوز 7 درجات على سلم ريختار واود بحياه
نحو 200 الف شخص وشرد نحو مليونين وبعد
تسعه ايام اعلنت الحكومه الهايتيه انتهاء
مرحله البحث والانقاذ مع تضاؤل فرص العثور
على المزيد من الاشخاص على قيد الحياه قله
من الاشخاص المحاصرين يمكنهم البقاء على
قيد الحياه لمده طويله خلال الزلازل واول
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه تعد حرجه لانها توفر
اعلى فرص لوجودنا جيم لكن يتعين على اجهزه
التنسيق في البلد المتضرر اتخاذ القرار
الصعب بشان متى تتوقف عن البحث عن الاشخاص
المحاصرين المتبقين تحت الانقاض متوسط
الوقت لذلك عاده ما يرابح بين خمسه ايام
وسبعه ويعتمد على عوامل مثل الطقس والهزات
الارتداديه ومدى سرعه وصول فرق الانقاذ
والمعدات لكن لخبراء في الزلازل تشير الى
ان الافراد يظلون على قيد الحياه لمده تصل
الى 13 يوما اذا كان لديهم امكانيه الوصول
الى الماء واكثر من ذلك اذا ما وفر لهم
الطعام العامل الاكثر الحاحا هو الحصول
على الرعايه الطبيه للاشخاص تحت المباني
المنهره قبل انهيار اجسادهم او نسفهم وفي
ظل لحاله الطقس الحاليه يعد انخفاض درجه
حراره الجسم امرا ممكنا وربما يموت الناس
للاسف بسبب ذلك وبدون ماء قد يفقد الكثير
منهم حياتهم تلتزم بعض فرق الانقاذ
الدوليه ما يعرف بقاعده الاربعه وتفترض
بقاء المحاصرين تحت الانقاض على قيد
الحياه لمده اربع دقائق دون هواء واربعه
ايام دون ماء واربعه اسابيع دون طعام
وتتحدث عن 48 ساعه ذهبيه يبقى القول ان
وقف عمليه الانقاذ قرار صعب الا انه
بالمقابل يسمح بتركيز الموارد على رعايه
الالاف من الناجين الاخرين وعمليه التعافي
والمساعده في ازاله الانقاض لهذا ووفق
بروتوكولات دوليه معتمده يجب ان يكون عمال
الانقاذ سريعين لتقييم الاماكن التي من
المرجح ان يجد فيها ناجين داخل المباني
المنهاره ويمكن الاستفاده من كاميرات
الفيديو عبر الفجوات الموجوده في الانقاض
ومعدات التصوير الحراري لتحديد اماكن
الناجين ويمكن لمعدات الصوت المتخصصه
اكتشاف اضعف الاصوات في نطاق امتار قليله
وتعد الكلاب المدربه فعاله للغايه
باستخدام حاسه الشم في كشف ناجين ناهيك
بتعاون المجتمعات المحليه في تحديد
الاماكن ويمكن ايضا استخدام اجهزه الكشف
عن ثاني اكسيد الكربون للعثور على الناجين
الذين فقدوا الوعي حيث يكتشف المنقذون
تركيزه في الهواء عند نفته ممن ما زالوا
يتنفسون
[موسيقى]
معنى من جناب الدكتوره ملغي
وهي المتحدثه باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه
اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي ما اكثر ما يشغل ما
يشغل بال منظمه الصحه العالميه الان في
تركيا وسوريا بعد
نا هو عدد الناس الذين يعيشون في ظروف
صعبه وصعبه للغايه في العراء دون ماوى
ودون طعام وكذلك اهميه وصول الماء النقي
والنظيف للناس ذلك لان
شوربه عمل مع الملوث ربما يصيبهم بامراض
والوضع صعب جدا خصوصا في سوريا
حيث ضرب زلزال هنالك تفشن لمرض الكوليرا
وهو منتشر وكذلك التهاب الكبد الوبائي
وكذلك الحصبه لذلك نحن قلنا غايه القلق
بشان انتشار الاوبئه امر اخر مهم جدا هو
توفير المستلزمات الطبيه والصحيه
للمستشفيات
الاطباء وطواقم التمريضيه تعمل في ظروف
صعبه وفي مستشفيات
تفتقد الكثير من الخدمات وهم يقومون بعمل
رائع في تقديم رعايه الصحيه للمرضى
والمصابين ولكنهم يواجهون الشح الامدادات
والمستلزمات الصحيه ومن المهم جدا نوفر
لهم هذه الامدادات هناك ايضا سيده هرس
مشكله
ثقل الاجراءات وبطئ الاجراءات في عمل
المنظمات الدوليه مع مشكله التمويل
هل هذا سيعطل نجده الناس في الوقت المناسب
انت
على مستوى منظمه الصحه العالميه قمنا بجمع
ثلاثه
ملايين دولار
[موسيقى]
ومتوفر لدينا 16 مليون دولار ولكن هذه
النقطه في بحر وليست بالكثيره ونحن بحاجه
الى توفير الاموال اللازمه لجمع الطواقم
والفرق والخدمات
وكذلك عمليات اعاده البناء الضروريه
واللازمه لمساعدته الناس الذين اعانوا هذا
الزلزال الرهيب والفضيع فيما يتعلق بسوريا
الكل الان يقول يجب ان ننحي جانبا
الاعتبارات السياسيه هل هذا امر سهل
بالنسبه لمنظمه مثل منظمه الصحه العالميه
في التعامل مع ما يجري في سوريا
نعمل في المناطق في سوريا التي عانت جراء
صراع ونحن نعمل هناك منذ حوالي عقد من
الزمان ودائما ندعو الى تنحيه
الجوانب السياسيه
جانبا نحن بشر ونحن بحاجه الى اعلى مستوى
من الرعايه الصحيه وعندما
تتداخل السياسه والصراعات هذا
يعرقل
امكانات وصولنا لان لمساعدتهم وبالتالي
دائما ندعو الى تنحيه التجاذبات السياسيه
والخلافه السياسيه جانبا علينا ان نركز
على تلبيه الاحتياجات وان نتعامل مع البشر
كبشر نعمل على انقاذ حياه الناس ونساعد
بعضنا بعض في هذه الجهود مع ذلك هناك شعور
بالمراره
وبالخيبه لدى السوريين في شمال غرب البلاد
كيف يمكن للمنظمات الدوليه ان تتفاعل مع
شعورك هذا
ما مروا به هو امر مروع وفضيع لالغايه ان
يعرفوا ان اقاربهم واحباؤهم تحت الركام
وانهم فقدوا الكثير والكثير وحياتهم
الصعبه اصلا باتت اكثر صعوبه وبالتالي
فاننا نتفهم مشاعر المراره والاحباط
وبالتالي في البدايه علينا نحترم هذه
المشاعر وثانيا ان نوفر المساعدات لهم هم
بحاجه الى مساعدتنا والى كرمنا في اسرع
وقت ممكن وهذا وهذه هي الاجابه الوحيده
على تساؤل كذاك شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتوره
مرجله هريسه المتحدثه باسمي منظمه الصحه
العالميه
تركيا وسوريا كان حاضرا ايضا في واشنطن
حيث قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
مساعده قطر للمنكوبين في تركيا وشمال
سوريا مثال على مبادرتها لمواجهه التحديات
الملحه وقال بلينكن بعد مباحثات له مع
نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ان بلاده
تلحظ كرم قطر في مساعدتها للمنكوبين في
تركيا وشمال سوريا جراء الزلزال
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني في مقابله مع
الجزيره عقب اجتماعه
في واشنطن ان هناك تحديات كثيره في الدخول
الى سوريا وان لدى قطر جمعيات خيريه وفرق
بحث وانقاذ هناك تقوم بتقديم المساعده
هناك تحديات كثيره اكيد
تواجهها الدخول الى سوريا والاستخدام
المعابر نحن على تنسيق مستمر مع الجانب
التركي حول كيفيه تقديم المساعدات لدينا
الجمعيات الخيريه القطريه موجوده في
الاراضي السوريه
وتقوم بتقديم المساعدات اللازمه وهناك بعض
فرق البحث والانقاذ من الهلال الاحمر
القطري متواجد هناك
وزير الخارجيه القطري قال كذلك انه ناقش
مع بلينكن ملف الاتفاق النووي ولقاءاته
الاخيره مع وزير الخارجيه الايراني واعلن
ان الوضع معقد فيما يتعلق بالمفاوضات
الخاصه بالملف النوويه الايراني
وحتى الان الموضوع معقد جدا نعتقد ولكن
يجب ان نستمر في الجهود الدبلوماسيه لعوده
الاطراف
المسؤول القطري قال ان القضايا التي
ناقشها مع بلينكن تضمنت الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والاجراءات الاسرائيليه واليه
احتواء التصعيد بالاضافه الى ملف
افغانستان والمفاوضات النوويه مع ايران
ناقشنا موضوع التصعيد اللي قاعد يصير الان
في فلسطين والاجراءات الاسرائيليه اللي
جالسه تتخذوا كيفيه احتواء وخفض التصعيد
هناك طبعا القضيه الثانيه كانت قضيه
افغانستان اللي اخذت حيز من النقاش
كيفيه التعامل مع الملف في هذا الوضع
الحساس
وكيفيه ايضا المضي قدما في التاكيد على
اتفاق الدوحه وعلى التزامات اتفاق الدوحه
تفرقنا ايضا الى موضوع ايران موضوع
الاتفاق النووي والوضع اللي اللي يمر فيه
هذا الاتفاق حاليا
كانت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
وزير الامن القوميه كثير او عزاء للشرطه
الاسرائيليه باعداد خطه على شاكله عمليه
السور الواقي التي نفذها جيش الاحتلال في
الضفه الغربيه عام 2002 والاستعداد
لتنفيذها الاحد المقبل في الاحياء
الفلسطينيه بالقدس المحتله ياتي ذلك في
اعقاب عمليه دهس نفذها احد السكان ضاحيه
العيساويه في القدس المحتله في مستوطنه
راموت اوقعت قتيلين وخمسه جرحى
قتلى وجرحى في عمليه ثالثه بالقدس خلال
اسبوعين
لها ما بعدها من تاثير على حكومه اليمين
في اسرائيل عمليه الدهس نفذها حسين قراقع
من حي العيساوي بالقدس المحتله في محطه
الانتظار الحافلات في الحي الاستيطاني
القدس حيث كانت المحطه تقتضد
بالاسرائيليين في ذروه نهار الجمعه قبل ان
يقوم مستوطن وشرطي باطلاق النار على منفذ
العمليه من مسافه السفر وقتله
نحن نتقدم في التحقيق وبالامكان القول ان
منفذ العمليه هو من سكان القدس الشرقيه في
الثلاثين من عمره حيث قام بقياده سيارته
وتوجيهها مباشره الى محطه الحافلات واصاب
عددا ممن كانوا ينتظرون هناك
الى موقع العمليه وصل وزير الامن القومي
اتمر بن جير حيث توعد بتضييق الخناق على
ضاحيه العيسوي بالقدس المحتله واتخاذ مزيد
من الاجراءات لمواجهه ما سماه الارهاب
بنشر الحواجز على ضاحيه العيساويه وتوقيف
كل سياره وتفتيشها اردت ان افرض حصارا عن
العيساويه لكن تمت عقبات قضائيه سنبحث
فيها لاحقا
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سارعت الى
اقتحام منزل منفذ العمليه واعتقلت زوجته
تحت تهديد السلاح بينما اوعز رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو بتسريع اغلاق المنزل
تمهيدا لهدمه وامر بتعزيز التدابير
الامنيه في القدس ومحيطها عمليه جديده في
القدس لا تنحصر نتائجها بما خلفته من قتلى
وجرحى بل تمتد ارتداداتها الى ما قد
تحملوه من ردود فعل من جانب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليمنيه التي وعدت
الاسرائيليين بعهد
الجزيره من موقع العمليه في مستوطنه راموت
قال وزير الطاقه الاوكرانيه من جالوشينكو
ان ضربات الروسيه على اوكرانيا منذ بدايه
الحرب الحقت اضرارا باكثر من خمسين بالمئه
من منشات الطاقه في البلاد وردا على سؤال
للجزيره قال وزير الطاقه الاوكراني ان
بلاده منفتحه على انشاء منطقه امنه طرحتها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه حول محطه
سبروجيا النوويه
لقد كانت هناك رؤيه لمنطقه امنه حول محطه
النوويه من طرف وكاله الطاقه النوويه ونحن
منفتحون على هذا نطلب خروج القوات الروسيه
من محطه ومحيطها دون ان تدخلها قوات
اوكرانيه ونطالب ايضا باعاده اداره المحطه
لموظفين ولكن الجواب كان واضحا باعلان
السلطات الروسيه اتخذها قرارا بان محطه
الاتحاديه وادارتها من شركه المصنعه روسيه
لا اجد ايانيه روسيه على التقارب لتنفيذ
منطقه امنه او اي شيء اخر
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الجوله لكن
تغطيتنا الاخباريه لهم احداث العالم
مستمره وخاصه زلزال تركيا وسوريا
وتداعياته وفي اطارها سنواصل التغطيه سواء
في الجوانب الانسانيه او من عين المكان